kneeling for the national anthem in a
free country is not that brave you might
lose a sponsorship you might gain a
sponsorship as we've seen even if you're
a third-rate player it's not brave
protesting in the streets against a
violent authoritarian government
accepting full well the risk of being
murdered by said government for doing so
is brave question of the day when it
comes to the recent conflict over the
NBA supporting China do you see any
irony in the progressive companies who
are supporting an authoritarian
communist you know what stretch that of
course you do so let me judge the
question who do you think is the most
hypocritical offender as it relates to
wellness in their handling of the Hong
Kong China conflict okay let me know let
me sort of set the stage here those are
no reason we the NBA other United States
companies they voiced support for China
and some of them have denounced any kind
of support for Hong Kong protests so why
does it matter well what we have here
you need understand the conflict we have
Chinese authoritarians versus the people
of Hong Kong who really are actively
fighting for democracy right yeah kind
of Reason history lesson
the British handed Hong Kong back to
China relatively recently they've had a
one country kind of two systems
agreement to give Hong Kong residents
some measure of independence from China
protests started when Hong Kong was set
to pass a bill allowing individuals to
be extradited to China this is important
it's like you're getting rapists no
right it's not because I think if you
said the United States can extradite
rapists and murderers from Mexico
people's like well due process but yeah
okay I understand them this is really
it's about extraditing protesters yeah
okay dissidents that's important they're
creating a law so that they can forcibly
remove and punish people who protest the
government well let me be clear before
we get some clips in the NBA the Hong
Kong protesters asking for a few things
okay
including China withdraw the extradition
of the bill that involves the
extradition they want charged against
the protesters to be dropped they want
them to investigate the police's use of
force during the protests and they want
to ultimately allow Hong Kong voters to
pick their leaders rather than the
current process which includes sort of
Beijing's involvement for those of you
who missed it you've seen some footage
here some more America's Stars and
Stripes
paraded by Hong Kong protesters angry at
their government stood out starkly in
the city on Chinese soil many fear their
freedoms are being eroded by Communist
China and the u.s. might be the only
suit
her power to stop it protesters held up
posters of Donald Trump and saying the
American National Anthem is cartoonishly
Asian man
so obviously the protests by the way
they erupted into violence there's even
some footage of Chinese police shooting
protesters point-blank warning here this
isn't a trigger warning this is a
warning of actual potential graphic
content that we've blurred it out and
removed some of the sound cops shooting
protesters point blank in the chest now
I wanted to show you all that too
because it's very important that we set
the context here before enter stage left
the ultra woke members of the NBA so
let's get to this because I've
complained about it but I don't think
they've put this all together
necessarily to see how sinister it
really can be so initially the Houston
Rockets right general manager how do you
pronounce Daryl Daryl Morey Maury I've
only ever read it anyway he tweeted
support for the Hong Kong protests yeah
after the tweet unsurprisingly Chinese
companies began cutting ties with the
team and the Chinese media suspended
broadcasts of NBA games and by the way
it should be noted that Houston pretty
popular in China because they won
yum-yummy yeah yeah yeah that's right
the very tall tiny good you you guys got
him you finally got one another so he
was forced to apologize right yeah then
a lot of NBA officials and players came
out and this is important I want you to
watch this clip because it's not just
all right I'm sorry they came out in
support of China listen to the language
here apologize
you know we love China we love you know
playing there I know for both of us
individually we go there you know once
or twice a year they show us the most
important love so you know we appreciate
as a fanbase and we love everything you
know they're about in and you know we
appreciate their support that they give
us individually and as an organization
so listen we we appreciate we love
everything there about ya as an
organization it'll be one thing if they
said hey we understand that the Chinese
people aren't necessarily represented by
the government or by the organization's
they're no he said we look like
everything how about putting a hedge
word in there while you're conversing
and now the NBA is forcibly ejecting
people who even bring Hong Kong sign or
pro Hong Kong signs to games understand
you're doing a job don't just what about
ISM and want to sort of lay a case here
as to why this is important it's not
just the NBA it goes to at the
entertainment Street big tech and
academia but let's start with the NBA
okay let's compare this with the NBA's
previous sort of woke virtue signaling
where they pulled out remember this from
an all-star game in in Charlotte North
Carolina because of the state's laws
regarding gender neutral bathroom yeah
they pulled this out NBA coach Steve
Kerr who he was extremely vocal by the
way in condemning Trump so-called Muslim
Band obviously knows it but right now
would have that much time but he claims
that no one has asked him about the
Chinese human rights abuses and instead
he tries to turn the tables and he talks
about the United States human rights
abuses something some some men coming or
other ar-15s watch people in China
didn't ask me about you know people
owning ar-15s and mowing each other down
in the mall I wasn't asked that question
it's a little different when you have
individuals and commit crimes in the
United States versus the government
who's run people over with tanks and
fired upon protesters at point blank in
the chest so I get it I get it
you don't like Trump you think he's a
dick but all of China is
as I said a minute ago yes it's not the
same thing
and it's not just a Hong Kong issue
that's important across the board China
they have one of the worst Human Rights
records in the history of the world yeah
that's what they hog-tie women during
forced abortion of course they jail
political dissidents they demolish
Christian churches unless you say well
your this is your bias they also not
only confiscate Bibles and Christians
torture Muslim leaders in detention
camps yes we gory by the way you can
also be found in the NBA lest you no no
that's not these are Chinese Muslims
quarterblack okay we girls are Chinese
Muslims no word yet by the way whether
the men of China can slap on Rouge and
take a dump in the girls room here's
hold that'll be the line they cannot
cross it's just amazing to me
you're gonna because a man can't go in a
woman's restroom at a restaurant you're
going to pull your all-star game when
people are getting punched in the
stomach tied to a table because they
have the nerve to have a second child
all of a sudden we're murky on the rule
book oh my gosh and this is important
too it's not just the NBA they've taken
the most Fleck there are other American
companies as well as organizations so
trying to think of other folk and
progressive companies oh remember
remember Nike Nike for those who
forgotten you remember Nikes woke ad
campaign led by a sideshow Kaepernick
don't believe you have to be like
anybody to be somebody
don't become the best basketball player
on the planet be bigger than basketball
believe in something even if it means
sacrificing everything totally unrelated
but he looks like a guy who's picked his
afro beyond its natural look go ahead
like yes you've pulled it too far
tighten it up a little bit Garrett to do
that go for microphone top not Richard
Simmons that's the general rule of thumb
forgot Nike who didn't know Nike has now
pulled the Houston Rockets merchandise
from Chinese stores well as shoes from
any pro Hong Kong designers wow that's
crazy yeah you're pulling shoes from
just designers who happen to be Pro Hong
Kong yeah um I really hope the NBA
suffers for this because I generally
don't like the NBA as a rule but even
with a WNBA well for the WNBA is a sin I
cannot look past but the NBA they're
getting it on both sides right now China
is giving them all kinds of crap well
obviously we're talking about that and
then people in the United States are
like what the hell we thought you guys
cared about people's rights we thought
you cared about us in general and now
you don't at all they're alienating fans
on both sides and I'm like good you
screwed up you had an obvious choice
line you guys are wrong done I'm glad
that the curtain is being pulled yeah
yeah this is this is about a financial
they showed the Ryan is what it is yeah
it really isn't about human rights by
the way speaking of rights hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
on YouTube just really bookmark the page
because notifications don't work anymore
check in new video every single day at 9
livestream on Thursday at 8 p.m. Eastern
and join Mudd Club lot of credit
outcomes luckily that's what keeps this
open there's a whole other episode up
today behind the paywall from OU club so
it doesn't just end with sports the
entertainment industry they're in on
this deal - so do you member when Disney
Lee threatened to stop filming in
Georgia at the same time Disney they
were partnering with state-owned Chinese
corporations to open a five point five
billion dollar Resort in Shanghai what
about the Ultra woke world of academia
and I don't want to get conspiratorial I
want you to check out all these sources
turns out that some of the same schools
who you know have a meltdown every
single time a conservative looks in
their general direction they've been
taking over a hundred and fifty eight
million dollars collectively from the
Chinese government to promote pro-china
propaganda and then we can go to the
video game industry they always you need
like you're the video gamer why do we
always screw up the video game industry
it's like to two industries that are a
license to print money yeah
video games in cannabis yeah and I don't
know why can't get it together because
they combine the two to logically a
lottery anyway last week gaming company
Blizzard a lot probably
I remember them back from early on it
was like Starcraft and or even before
that there was a game called black thorn
and super Nintendos anyone else remember
that I like that game anyway Blizzard
yeah I have will play it later we'll
play it in the green when I have it I
have the original Callie have the
cartridge no emulators here so Blizzard
they banned a player took away his prize
money after he voiced support for Hong
Kong at an interval after people protest
the decision Blizzard overturned it
saying that the band had nothing to do
with China alright we'll take them it
there we'll take them up the word on
that one we'll move on because they're
other companies to get to to tour in
federal Apple and Microsoft they've
banned Hong Kong protest apps apps that
actually have assisted people with
protest Google they recently censored
material for China now keep in mind this
is the same company there's openly
changed policies thanks to yours truly I
apologize again as it relates to hate
speech guidelines should someone cause
an affront to the LGBTQA a IP community
by using one's biologically proper
pronouns cut YouTube has changed Google
has changed algorithms for that what's
the Chinese government's view on LGBTQ
rights the question anyone else anyway
want I guess take a wild guess not good
not good yes okay see me discriminated
against and housing they I don't mean
like Don't Ask Don't Tell I mean like
tell you die that's the policy
you tell you die now yes you died now so
obscure egg its housing military they
can't adopt and as far as I know you can
only get your you change your gender if
you get a full full surgery full
tapenade yeah which basically that's
yeah I don't I mean I don't the full top
and bottom which let's be honest if
they're gymnasts who can tell the
difference here's the thing right
they're not racist the United States is
more racist than China namely because we
have more races than China but they
actually won when given the opportunity
to be racist or discriminatory they
forced Muslims to drink alcohol
this is before shopkeepers yet in China
therefore shopkeepers to sell alcohol
and tobacco even if they're Muslim
shopkeepers and the we girls you why
quarterblack carat and this is something
they got it wrong
Communist China authoritarian but the
reason they do that is they recognize
the political threat that Islam presents
so they shut it down outright because
they see Islam as a political
prescription which is incompatible with
China where's here in the United States
when dr. ben Carson said I don't think
that the Quran and Sharia law is
compatible if the United States
Constitution people absolutely lost
their my right gosh but we say hold on a
second you don't need four witnesses for
rape Sharia law says you do he was 100%
correct I wanted to really clear about
something it because we'd have to get
the James O'Keefe and yet one second
want to be really clear this isn't what
about ISM okay this isn't well Donald
surge some of Donal Trump's policies are
bad but China is worse
well what are they care about no no this
is this is a there is no comparison ISM
right okay this is let's let's you have
one world leader okay you don't like
Donald Trump because of his attitude and
his tweets I understand that the other
is a government that perpetually and
systematically abuses its citizens most
fundamental basic human rights by force
on a regular basis not what about ISM
it's you don't have a moral lens through
which to establish your worldview is a
mile caught with a lot of isms right now
I'm on a roll worst of all worst of all
it's cowardice it's cowardice cloaked as
virtue the same industries by the way
that they pat themselves on the back for
being brave no okay
listen kneeling for the national anthem
in a free country is not that brave you
might lose a sponsorship you might gain
a sponsorship as we've seen even if
you're a third-rate player it's not
brave protesting in the streets against
a violent authoritarian government
accepting full well the risk of being
murdered by said government for doing so
is brave and you know what NBA you know
what Apple Google Mike Microsoft
Facebook like you know in order to be
brave here's the beauty right now you
don't even have to do that you don't
even have to stand up against an
authoritarian government that would kill
you you just have to grow the balls to
not throw the people under the bus as
they are actually fighting for their
freedom all you have to do to be brave
right now is throw a little bit of
support their way but you won't do it
because you're all cowards and I guess
that's why you kneel for our anthem and
the American flag
well these freedom fighters wave it
ravely overhead Hong Kong I know there's
not that much I can do for you but know
that we hear you and we appreciate you
yes China is a so I hope you enjoyed
this clip if you don't these are the
ABCs of me baby you can just click Next
video and put it in double speed of
course search doesn't necessarily work
subscriptions notifications don't
necessarily work just bookmark this page
chicken we do a new video every single
day except for Sunday and if you don't
want this content to disappear join my
club at ladder with credit comm slash
mug club it's only $69 if your student
header interactive military and if you
don't you know listen I I don't want to
say that your hellbound but it that
doesn't look good for you